we're admiral Keith Smith is the
commander of the US Coast Guard's fifth
District which includes North Carolina
he strategically positioned ships
aircraft boats and crews to respond
after the storm Rear Admiral Smith joins
us by phone from his district's
headquarters in Portsmouth Virginia
thank you so much for joining us
when will it be safe enough for your
team to go out and start rescuing people
that need help well good morning and
thank you so we like you said we have
resources positioned our people ready to
respond and as this storm has Lawrence
makes landfall we're just kind of
watching right now and when the
conditions allow our biggest concern
right now is the wind and so helicopters
boats ready to respond but we have to
wait for the wind conditions to subside
and right now we're evaluating that I'm
basically on an hourly basis and when
the conditions permit and we can operate
safely we will put our resources into
into play and yet the storm surge is
something that we're obviously focused
on as well aside from the wind
this storm is expected to stall for days
how does that impact your operations and
your planning no it's a great question
so that you know right now helicopters
we have hunt boats we have we have 24
helicopters 10 fixed-wing aircraft and
20 lines shallow water boats ready to
respond and this is kind of an all of a
Coast Guard response brought in from all
over the country to ready to respond so
the surge is a problem we're going to go
through several several cycles of high
tides during the storm so a lot of
flooding is going to be impacted so a
little bit of a challenge but right now
it's probably the biggest challenge we
have is the wind so that the tides will
be a little bit of a problem and getting
our boats in and so we have position
those and they're ready to respond so
it'll be a little bit of a challenge but
we expect that we will be able to get
through that right now the wind is our
biggest challenge real quickly are their
tankers out at sea and other big ships
they can't get out of the way of this
and are you worried about them so right
before the storm we went out and we did
a search and search and rescue Patrol
announced all the ships to get out but
that's it is smaller vessels to get off
the water most of them give you that one
and the larger ships have sailed out and
right now we don't have any we have had
no concerns about ships that see that
are in trouble right now
we did have a couple of calls
nice of some ships to try to solve
smaller vessels to try to relocate
getting a little bit of trouble but we
were able to provide assistance and they
were able to kind of self help
themselves but but we have no
indications of anybody distressed
offshore right now well that's good news
Rear Admiral Smith we thank you very
much